[Musique]
la vie si tout concorde est astucieux
peine
fait monsieur le plus sérieux à jouer et
me benoît devenu un ami
sinon bonjour fabrice carbillet ne
publie trop là je suis du travail fait
du bricolage en semences regardera
détourne les torts hier les tours de
passe passe que je ferai oui qu'est-ce
que toi est ce que tu fais je viens de
faire apparaître aussi le petit bout de
ses jetons ordinaires cédées cet
étonnant qu est ce que tu peux faire
pour être issus et bah moi je moi je
jongle avec deux boules seulement tu as
tu bien maladroit malades maladroit
alors été sûr je jongle tu vois je
georges donc voilà c'est fini à sept
sports pour aujourd'hui
très bien nous allons fait un peu de
géographie voilà si tu aimes la
géographie oui qu'est ce que tu veux que
nous fassions pour commencer le jeu
habituel avec les trois éléments les
trois éléments qui sont derrière le
tableau
oui c'est quelles fleurs aujourd'hui des
idées aux autres c'est une églantine
oui une église ni la hot line réel
bonheur je commence par la carte
géographique du pays que vous devez
découvrir à tous c'est pas facile facile
me fait peur là oui tu vas aimer parce
qu'il ya la mer oui très belle cote la
wii sa mère puis la capitale
alors maintenant le rapport drap
voilà bah le drapeau le connaît que dire
des couleurs - alors le drapeau tu veux
me dire les couleurs alors nous avons
des bandes verticales la première
horizontale oui horizontale par n'est
pas bien non bâchés fait un moment que
ça arrive à tout le monde vient alors la
première hausse et bleu en dessous c'est
blanc wii rouge en bas oui ville et
wallons sur le sur le blond et voilà
voilà exactement alors sait déjà c'est
une indication non j'étais dire une
chose nous auront certainement du mal à
dire bonjour dans la langue du pays vue
qui en a six je solde landes où il ya
six langues dans le pays il l'a après de
commode de pendant la liane foly alors
il leur compte
tu vois d'ailleurs ground and the bride
hand ball dames et double dames alors
moi je vais t'expliquer oui la bri je
vais t'expliquer tu as le choix tu vois
on alors dobermann c'est du serbo-croate
et d'aubry dance et du slovène
ah bon voilà parce que on pourrait
peut-être rappeler nos amis que ce pays
est composé de différentes républiques
si ma mémoire ne me trompe pas tu dois
avoir la serbie la croatie la slovénie
la bosnie herzégovine la macédoine et le
monténégro et je crois qu'ils ont tous
leur langue particulière est la
principale c'est serbo-croate voilà
enfin à peu près c'est un petit peu
compliqué et tout cet ensemble forme la
yougoslavie avec la capitale belgrade
qui est ici et le drapeau yougoslave
ah ben voilà mpeg là tu as tout tu as un
ensemble on a appris bien des choses je
les ai dit absolument les amis rue
d'image fait dans le jardin voilà examen
c'est une bonne idée
toujours dans le finistère jour argent
via alors nous maintenant eh ben on va
préparer points communs l'érudit vous
n'êtes pas mais bien les rues dit oui
les rues et les reussilles et donc non
ça marche pas bien
ne vous moquez pas de moi s'il vous
plaît un jeu à licence à sa voisine
ça veut dire l'instruit alors le point
commun oui il rappelle alors le point
commun il est très simple tout cancan
belles belles et pousse moussu reboisant
de chacun quelque chose quel est le
point qu'ils ont en commun qu'est la
chose qu'ils ont en commun
c'est ce que nous allons découvrir tous
ensemble je commence tout con con tu es
quoi aux gens alors aujourd'hui
moi j'ai été très utile mais chers
petits enfants quand vous étiez en
vacances
oui l'été dernier parce que quand vous
êtes sur les plages vous aimez courir
sauter vous lancer des ballons voulait
rattraper voulait renvoyer de plus en
plus fort pour que les autres ne
puissent pas les rattraper et au
quelquefois si je n'étais pas là et puis
on en finirait jamais remarquez bien que
quelquefois vous fait souffrir
faut voir dans quel état je suis à la
fin de la saison j'ai des trous partout
je m'en vais en lambeaux croyez moi j'ai
souvent besoin de passer à l'atelier
pour les réparations
voilà bah je suis pas je suis pas je
suis pas vraiment je suis pas dans le
coup là j'écoute belle belle perf' moi
je me suis pas là pour m'amuser nippo
vous amuser
ma vie n'est pas un jeu comme pour tout
cas encore
j'ai des préoccupations plus importantes
mois tous les matins il faut que je
fasse les courses et ça me prend du
temps il faut acheter du lait du pain du
beurre à kilo de poireaux trois livres
de pommes de salades et pommes de terre
il faut transporter tout ça je ne peux
plus
et c'est là que je vous rends service à
vous avez bien besoin de moi et
croyez-moi quand vous me portez ça tire
sur les bras
kissimmee âge commence alors une [ __ ]
d'idée ma part oui
bush moussaoui au bar au banjo alors moi
moi moi je serais plutôt comme tout cas
encore oui un bon souvenir de vacances
eh bien naturellement si si vous avez
passé vos vacances au bord de la mer car
c'est seulement là que je suis utile et
là avec moi au on s'amuse bien
croyez-moi on a besoin de personne
on me prend on m'emmène au bord de l'eau
aux propos très loin jusqu'à ce que j'ai
de l'eau eau à peu prés jusqu'aux genoux
quoi alors là ça suffit
alors là on me promène pendant une heure
ou deux et alors quand on revient vous
savez ce qu'on peut faire grâce à moi eh
bien on peut manger des crevettes et
quelquefois même jeu je vous permet de
rapporter des crabes
alors là là là faut faire très attention
à la c'est moins drôle parce que là on
risque de se faire pincer ou lola voilà
c'est tout il espère que moi je pense
que cette fois-ci vous avez tous trouvés
sans grande difficulté car tout de même
les éléments donnés par tous cancan
belles belles et pousse reçues sont
assez évidents je crois tout quand que
tu es le filet de des buts de football
par exemple par le oui oui un oui ou de
handball mais voilà bien voilà alors ça
c'est ça effectivement vous avez eu un
fils il y a également pour bell bell une
question de filet car il s'agit des
défis leur vision de la provision et
enfin qu'on pousse le sud il s'agit du
filet de pêche bien sûr à braga et
il a encore prouvé aujourd'hui salle pas
trop délicat qu'il est fan bravo c'était
bien trop fabrice et c'est quand même
quelqu'un il est fort d'ailleurs je vais
vous montrer que c'était encore
quelqu'un est toujours quelqu'un car il
va jouer avec moi dans peu de temps
j'arrive à tout de suite un ami a tout
de suite à belvèze
oui fabrice jacques c'est à nous oui
c'est oui c'est notre jeu oui oui tout
cas encore tu restes avec nous on tient
alors fabrice tu vas aller au tableau
oui et j'espère que tu n'as pas oublié
ton marqueur regarde il est là il va me
down oublie jamais rêvé il dit peut-être
qu'un jour il va l'oublier
dis moi tout à fait entre nous
l'orthographe ah ben moi l'orthographe
oui je ne sens rien dire madame quand tu
as raison nous savons très bien quelles
sont les capacités dans ce domaine
et oui voilà alors cette semaine à un
mot en six lettres on commence pas alors
on commence par un l aile
elle rit oui à leurs quatre petits prêts
oui à noter 1 2 3 4 et la dernière 1ère
marche pas ça tu as vu tu l'as à
l'accrocher au hasard oui oui tu as mal
travaillé alors la dernière c'est un 1er
ouais bon qu'est-ce que ça peut bien
être que c'est s'étale c'est une plante
on m'a dit non je croyais que tu allais
me dire que c'était un animal une plante
et ben c'est une plante a raison car
quand je suis chez toi tout quand tu
achètes une émission si c'est toi je
t'ai vu ton corps
on nous fâchons pas c'était très amusant
j'ai en effet rihanna a
c'était une donc c'est une plante elle
fait une plante que l'on mange et que
l'on mange oh oui oh oui car oui oui
dans la cuisine y en a beaucoup
les ménagères aime beaucoup cette plante
non ça se mange dans un potage par
exemple eh oui dans le nord dans l'est
dans les sources et c'est souvent
accompagnées de temps tu vois ce que je
veux dire
veux-tu la troisième lettre parce que je
crois que tu as presque trouvé
lalalalala fait trop d'éléments la
troisième lettre oui la 3e net c'est un
air et tu me dis que ça avec le teint we
were oui voilà au c'est pas vrai mais si
mais si
mais comment tu écris lauriers et ben
lauriers mais tu as trouvé ses lauriers
également que j'ai trouvé seulement ce
qui m'amuserait c'est de savoir ce que
tu mets ici comme là un ol au rpr oui
laurier thym et laurier et lau herri rer
b oui lauriers lors lors c'est normal
n'est ce pas tous en commun c'est bien
va bien très bien est aussi mauvais l'un
que l'autre
l'envié elle a eu et pas hello hello hey
oui d'ailleurs quand tu vois tu m'a pas
aidé du tout et vous savez vous ne
faites aucun progrès ça ne va pas du
tout ses lauriers sa série comme ça
enfin et non pas hello how ça veut dire
où l' iphone os en la monarchie ça c'est
minable semir il faut tellement
imminente de chocolat que tu que tu as
dit fabrice oui je ne sais pas si un
jour je passerai mon baccalauréat
l es tu sais rien à propos de lauriers
on n'en donnait aux bons élèves
qu'est ce que c'est que ce ballon chaud
et on ne peut pas jouer non qu'est ce
que c'est que ce ballon tous deux de
passe-passe ya alors qu'est ce que c'est
que j'y mois à les tarifs ou est tu sais
qu'on a donnée aux bons élèves
oui aux bons élèves ddd l'oignon le
lyonnais des récompenses oui c est le
mot baccalauréat vient de là oui quand
on était reçue on recevait un diplômé et
une couronne de lauriers et voilà c'est
exact c'est exact c'est parfaitement
vrai ils ont tu as fini d'embêter ton
camarade cancan
mais tu vas lui c'est en malo dans la
vallée pas pour cela les regarde il
étouffe pour à tanger les jolies tuer
lui prendre angad mois sans travail ni
gfa gay mais tout ça m'a choqué ça va
mieux grâce à fait terminée oui oui on
va leur trouver des visuels menée dans
le jeu la wii allait très vite belbacha
fabrier réduire aussi le jeu music story
et de temps en temps j'ai laissé un mot
inachevé que tu complet par une note de
musique
on y va et à la fin les petites notes de
musique francs le début d'une chanson
bonjour voila c'est l'histoire d'un
personnage important mais distrait
écervelée qui a toujours besoin de
quelqu'un qui se tiennent à côté de lui
pour lui donner des conseils tout seul
il est incapable de prendre une décision
décision très bien il tend peu ridicule
ce personnage je dirais qu'il ne voit
rien qu'il n'entend rien il le fait
aussi on a rien de ce qui se passe
autour de lui il ne fait même pas
attention à la façon dont il s'habille
il faut tout nu tire tout ligne allait
lui signaler par n'a donc ce personnage
quand il lui prend vie dans des d'aller
à l'achat ravive tu imagine ce que ça
peut donner lé risquerait de tuer
société monde les mappemondes roi
maladroit compris on a intérêt à ne pas
rester à côté de lui car il faut le
reconnaître c'est une véritable calamité
calamité l'a fait partie de ces gens qui
vont tout à l'envers quand il pleut il
prêt d'une ombrelle ils ont toujours un
parapluie quand il ya du soleil soleil
ou à elle seule je vais trouver moi
oui à lui dos non comme je t'ai dit
fabrice ce personnage et auprès de lui
un ami qui ne le quitte pas qui
surveille ses moindres gestes
ce qui fait que ce pauvre homme n'a
jamais droit à une minute
1 étude sans l'étude
tu la place sol sol à l'aldi les notes
maintenant sicile à la soul soul keith
et chante
[Musique]
un dc jusqu'au brême qui sait que la
tête voilà aussi parce ici là la seule
somalie
voilà c'est fait et bien alors on va
enchaîner avec notre petite chanson que
tu connais par coeur
absolument j'arrive tout de suite rapide
et cela connaît aussi la nhtsa lient
déjà papa papa d'amy d'état qui me plaît
que la vie majeur désiste et j'ai shops
et des chances mais comme jenny pas de
baignoire negro a fait attention les
cadres y sont repartis sans rien dit
mais fiat
ça me semble heureux car il aime la vie
oui
oh oui
il a joué aujourd'hui et famille vouloir
devenir amis
j'ai remarqué taper dans un ballon la
faire tomber
[Musique]